wendy sherman subsecretaria de estado
reiteró que si moscú decide invadir a
ucrania pues las sanciones que eeuu
impondría las sanciones y las acciones
que eeuu y pondría esta vez serían mucho
más severas que en el 2014 cuando rusia
invadió la península de crimea reiteró
también la subsecretaría que depende de
rusia de escalar la situación y que si
esto no ocurre eeuu incrementaría aún
más la asistencia en seguridad que le
está brindando ya a ucrania reiteró
también la subsecretaría que el des
escalamiento de esta situación depende
sobre todo de que precisamente rusia
decida sacar decide retirar estas más de
100 mil tropas que tiene en la frontera
entre rusia y ucrania reiteró de eeuu
que está en constante comunicación con
sus aliados europeos de cara a los
próximos día los que tengan que tendrán
diálogos que tendrán oficiales rusos con
organismos europeos bueno cristóbal y
del otro lado cuál es la visión de rusia
respecto a estas conversaciones y cuál
es la agenda de los próximos días en
ginebra
usted mencionaba bien no se llegó
concretamente a nada lo que decía
también a la secretaria de estado era
que estas eran conversaciones previas
para entender mejor cuáles eran las
preocupaciones las preocupaciones de
rusia que lo ha mencionado ya varias
veces es que precisamente la otan no
crezca más hacia el este de europa no
incluya ucrania y esto le preocupa rusia
precisamente porque esto avalaría a la
opción de que eeuu pueda seguir con
operaciones militares muy cerca la
frontera de rusia rusia sin embargo
reiteró también en una rueda de prensa
que hizo paralelamente a la conversación
que tuvo la subsecretaria con
periodistas en eeuu que rusia no tiene
interés de invadir a ucrania sin embargo
a eeuu les sigue preocupando que las
tropas sigan ahí sigan en la frontera
ruso-ucraniana el miércoles entonces se
reunirá oficiales rusos oficiales de
moscú con oficiales de la otan y el
jueves será con la organización de
cooperación de seguridad europea el
viernes posiblemente habrá un comunicado
conjunto entre rusia eeuu y los aliados
europeo sobre estos diálogos estos
diálogos extraordinarios